thank you so my first of all thank you
for being so brave to come out tonight
the country's still in the grips of
deflategate and you were able to come
outside that's the scandal of the
century ladies and gentlemen have you
been following this casting a very dark
shadow on the New England Patriots I
don't know if you know what's going on
but much like Sarah Palin's brain 11
have their balls did not get enough air
and this is nothing matters in America
now except if like I worry that this
will distract us quite frankly from what
is really important is anyone keeping
track of whether Kim Kardashian's ass is
still big and round I mean on CNN you
would have thought that Tom Brady caught
Ebola passed out at the controls of a
Malaysian airliner and crashed into
Benghazi oh yeah yeah
as I tell you if the NFL does not get to
the bottom of this how can it restore
the integrity of grown men giving each
other brain damage so in other news King
Abdullah of Saudi Arabia died yesterday
did you see that I know good night sweet
prince I'll always think of you when I
go to an Italian restaurant and see the
tablecloth oh please please I know I
know I'm crestfallen too he was one of
the best friends we ever invaded for and
now the crown passes to his brother Jeb
no no I'm sorry
Salman Salman is the now the king of
Judea Arabia Prince uh King Salman he is
80 ravaged by dementia and has
Alzheimer's disease it's always so sad
there when they don't even recognize
their own wives
yeah they say prince picking some and
he's really gone they say he will say
something one minute and then the next
minute say the complete opposite like
Mitt Romney oh I kid Mitt Romney we're
gonna talk about her oh it was a kind of
a tough week for conservative this week
it was the anniversary of Roe vs. Wade
and they had a big mall got National
Mall gathering there where they did a
profile it of March for the pro-life
folks and speaker after speaker got up
there and affirmed that everywhere we
look life should be affirmed it is a
precious gift and then they all went
home and watched their favorite movie
American sniper and that wasn't bad
enough for conservatives then at the
State of the Union address on Tuesday
did you see that oh my god Obama came
out wow he really gave it to the
Republicans well he really gave it at
the first he's is he I mean this guy he
has not really spoken like this since I
don't know when maybe 2008 and right I
mean this was the old ninja Obama and
what the weird thing was I mean this is
the first time the first State of the
Union after he lost the Senate after the
disastrous November election he gets off
on abuse he does it's like 50 shades of
black in the White House
know everything everything he said that
the Republicans wanted to do he said
he's gonna veto everything they hate he
made a case for he talked about raising
the minimum wage he talking about free
college he talked about upping the
capital gains tax open up Cuba and then
came the Republican rebuttal and Joni
Ernst talked about the time she wore
bread bags on her feet
what are you that's the difference
between the two parties he gets down to
reality I loved it that a part of the
speech he devoted to global warming he
said it's real we've got to do something
about it he said rising oceans longer
heat waves dangerous droughts floods and
of course the Republicans said there is
no proof the global warming caused
floods but if if they do we we could put
bread bags on our feet what the [ __ ] is
that all about bread bags on my feet and
then of course the greatest moment I've
ever seen in the State of the Union you
saw you know and I'm gonna bit okay
so Obama he's saying at one point I have
no more campaigns to run
and the Republicans start applauding you
know cuz they're classy and then Obama
goes I know because I won both of them
Oh talk about deflated balls